I think in season one once you've set up this
is what the show is you're always open to have
a little more fun and yet still deepen the whole
experience for the character and the viewer all
right we're going to when he says i wish i prefer
if you took him have grogu look up at dad like
really okay and then she starts talking and
then have him look back to her okay but just
this little moment like if my dad said i prefer
you took him dude what are you talking about
yeah not like shocking no but just but
just like yeah acknowledging yourself
yeah i don't like bringing characters in unless
there's a real value to it so when i wrote the
episode with her and it this year it really
was about how can we learn this child's name
who would know these things grogu
and i can feel each other's thoughts
What's fascinating with her she's the first
character that we've met that really actually
knew yoda so for her it's bringing back
all these memories and things that aren't
unlike what the viewer experienced as well
when they saw the child for the first time
I learned so much making that episode you know
and i hope to bring that to future episodes never
stop learning that's the way of the jedi never
stop learning you want to hold him call the baby
that's your great great great
grandfather
everything in this episode is in a
stage it's in the volume of the stage
but if you look at the story it happens entirely
outside so we're doing that for various lighting
reasons and because the volume you know will offer
fantastic results but we have to get a sense of
atmosphere of particles to make i think this feel
like we truly were in this location if you watch
any chorus off film and the amount of wind that's
blowing the sensibility it's giving the story but
just something to consider that the environment
itself should be a big part of playing this story
if you watch like the great sword
fights like in samurai children
any of them they're always measuring each other
because one wrong move and that's deadly yeah
with dave's episode we really
really start to get into
nuance it is something that
tonally i found particularly
artful and also amazing to see him bring in
an animated character of his into live action
I intentionally did not do anything with her
in season one because i want to mess it up
the character that george and i created she's one
of the first things i ever drew for clone wars
we cast ashley eckstein to be the voice of the
character and she brought such a great energy
to ahsoka in the animated series people know
this character they've watched her grow up and
the challenge was to take all of the elements
we had and evolve them into this live-action
version so cool i think we just have the hood
down for this scene in this moment and she
would have put it down off screen when we do the
attacks and the kills you'll have it up it'll be
cool so already coming out with it already coming
out with the hood down look at this cool i like
losing that business this is so strong your face
is so strong there you go there are moments when
i just stare at her and i'm just like wow
she just looks like this thing i've drawn
Rosario's done all the research like she knows
the character but now she has to become it
in a way that's never happened before. Welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is going to be my new
mandalorian season 2 video for the bonus episode
that they dropped through the disney gallery
program there's just a whole bunch of extra
material from the making of season 2 in a bunch
of really cool extra details that they didn't
reveal during the actual episodes if you're new to
the channel i'll be doing videos for mandalorian
season 3 and all the other mandalorian spin-off
shows that they announced including the ahsoka
tano series that they're going to be filming next
year so i'll explain what's going on with that
what dave filoni has said about those episodes
careful for spoilers from everything that happened
during the mandalorian season 2 just because we'll
be talking about everything that happened during
these episodes but just starting with the biggest
stuff first obviously the biggest thing here
is all about dave filoni bringing his animated
characters that he's been living with for so
long into live action and when he decided to
do that how he decided to do that and why he
decided to wait to season 2 to do ahsoka tano
the way he explains it during all these videos is
that he decided to do this a long long time ago
especially when he was talking to katie sakhoff
about bo katan when she first started recording
the lines years and years ago he said if this
works out we could do this in live action someday
she of course didn't believe him but obviously
he was thinking the same thing for ahsoka tano
he always wanted to bring her into live action but
just didn't know when that was going to happen or
when the opportunity would arise then they start
doing the mandalorian series and it seems like the
perfect place to do that but the whole reason why
he didn't do ahsoka tano during season one as he
explains it is because they were still figuring
so many things out about what they were capable
of doing that he didn't want to mess it up when he
had this big chance so that's why they waited to
season 2 to they figured out the technology and
what worked what didn't work during season one
if you remember season one episode five was
one of the most heavily criticized episodes and
when people found out that it was dave filoni that
wrote and directed that episode they were actually
pretty critical of them after the fact i had to
go back to my video that i made for that episode
to read everyone's comments and i would say on
the whole just based on people's comments they
felt like that was one of the weakest episodes
from season one but the ahsoka tano episode from
season 2, season 2 episode 5 was probably one of
the best episodes in one of the best homages to
classic samurai films like kurosawa they get into
that very clearly so obviously there are a lot of
direct references they intentionally made with the
way they filmed things the look the feel the tone
because all the classic star wars films are
inspired by kurosawa films like you see george
lucas here all over the footage watching them
film the ahsoka episode clearly that was the
episode that he came to watch because it was such
a big deal he also helped create the ahsoka tano
character way back when they were working on the
clone wars if you weren't really familiar with
his involvement in the clone wars when dave filoni
first started on that he was actually relatively
low ranking compared to where he exists sort of
in the hierarchy of lucasfilm right now he's a
much more powerful person inside lucasfilm
at the moment but george lucas was heavily
involved in the early seasons of clone wars and
then as things got on and they started to take
more and more responsibilities on themselves
he would just sit in on the really big stuff
and check in on what they were doing give them
hints tips and help them create new things like
when they were creating the darksaber for the
first time george lucas was a big part of that
he also explains when he decided to cast rosario
dawson it's because get this of fan art so never
let it be said that fan casting never works what
happened is a couple years ago people were posting
fan art of rosario dawson talking about how she'd
be amazing this is okatano dave filoni saw that
art and said you know what she would be amazing
as ahsoka tano so this was still in the very early
developmental stages of the mandalorian season one
they hadn't even started filming yet but because
they knew they were going to do this live-action
show he's like you know what if i ever did ahsoka
live-action she would be amazing and because jon
favreau had worked with rosario dawson before
dave filoni had him reach out to her and talk
to her about doing ahsoka tano live action and
of course she was totally down for it so the way
they portray her in the episode because this is
meant to be a big samurai film homage is sort of
a ronin samurai without a master only in the case
of ahsoka tano is without a jedi master although
they do reference yoda during the episode when
talking about grogu in why he decided for this
to be the episode where they reveal so much about
grogu's backstory the way he says it it was all
about his name how do we reveal his name because
they decided that his name was going to be grogu
pretty early on in the development process of the
mandalorian series even back in season one they'd
known his name for a long time they just chose to
wait to this point to reveal it but the reason
why it became the ahsoka episode is because he's
a former jedi padawan just like her because he's
a member of yoda's species and she had this long
history of learning from yoda this relationship
with him going back to the clone wars when she was
young like grogu and because on a practical level
he can't speak out loud as far as we know unless
he's kind of hiding that from us so only someone
who could read his thoughts could tell you exactly
what he's trying to say the other really cool
thing that they talk about is the way they filmed
her lightsaber fight scenes and how that's evolved
from the original star wars movies through the
modern films they used to use really reflective
material that would break it was really hard to
film with way back in the day like you see mark
hamill practicing his lightsaber fight scenes for
return of the jedi and empire strikes back then
when they got to the prequel movies they evolved
that just a little bit now the tech is even more
advanced than that and they actually have the
lightsabers light up on screen so that they can
frame the shots very differently like they talk
about how the lightsabers illuminate her face now
and you get shots like this where it completely
shapes her face in the darkness here and it looks
perfect probably one of the coolest shots from
one of these fight scenes during this episode
they wouldn't have been able to do shots like
this during the original star wars movies or even
during the prequels and as you can kind of see as
they've done with the other mandalorian episodes
this episode for sokatana was sort of like a pilot
for the ahsoka tano spinoff series like okay let's
test and see what we can do with her character
then we'll take it way further down that road
when we get to her episodes and for those of
you wondering what's going on with the ahsoka
tano series episodes dave filoni himself per
john favreau is writing all the episodes himself
right now as we speak the way they talk about it
john favreau and dave filoni are going to sort of
run the mandalorian cinematic universe of shows
there are four of them currently if you include
the mandalorian so you have the mandalorian you
have the ahsoka tano series you have the book
of boba fett episodes and then you have that new
republic series but even though we probably won't
see those ahsoka tano series episodes until 2022
she will come back and cameo during the
mandalorian season 3 and possibly the other series
as well but the way jon favreau and dave filoni
talk about it all the main characters will cross
over to each other's shows just like the marvel
cinematic universe movies the whole thing with the
ahsoka tano series is that she will just continue
being that ronin jedi traveling around the galaxy
looking for grand admiral thrawn and because of
the timing of their big avengers endgame sort
of team-up moment when they all go after grand
admiral thrawn we might get some sort of stinger
at the end of mandalorian season 3 where we see
his fleet in the chimera the other star destroyers
maybe we'll see him on screen for the first time
they might wait to the ahsoka tano episodes though
to actually reveal his face on screen so we
learn who the actor is actually going to be
i know everyone's pulling for benedict cumberbatch
i guess we'll just have to wait and find out i'm
sure there's going to be a ton of rumors in the
next year about who's playing grand admiral thrawn
the whole thing with luke skywalker too like he
says is that they're very careful about which
characters they bring in it has to be completely
in the service of the story the way they talk
about grogu is that he'll continue to be an
important part of the show but the way they
talk about luke skywalker makes it sound like
this is meant to be a very special thing and he
won't be showing up all the time so they'll find
clever ways of showing you grogu without showing
you luke skywalker but you can't really tell his
story at least at the beginning of the mandalorian
season 3 without talking about luke skywalker so
there'll be some clever ways of referencing him
without having to do a ton of deep fake scenes
just waiting for that jedi montage just see
like a giant buffed up version of grogu running
around with luke skywalker riding on his back
i know we're all just hoping to see some sort
of hayden christensen anakin skywalker crossover
maybe force ghost anakin maybe a flashback scene
that'd be a bit of a stretch but if we hear any
news about potential hayden christensen cameos in
the ahsoka tano series or potential ahsoka tano
cameos in the obi-wan kenobi series i will totally
do a video about it while you wait for everything
click here for all my mandalorian season 3 episode
videos and click here for that teaser trailer for
the obi-wan kenobi series thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!